روايات متضاربه حول عدد ضحايا قمع النظام
الايراني للمحتجين وكاله ميزان التابعه
للقضاء تتحدث عن اكثر من 100 قتيل وقبلها
اقل قيادي في الحرس الثوري بمقتل اكثر من
300 اغلبهم في كردستان ايران
الارقام الرسميه الايرانيه تضم قتل في
صفوف الامن في محاوله لتبرير استخدام
القوه ضد المتظاهرين حسب المعارضات
الايرانيه
حسب منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه ومقارها
تتحدث عن قرابه 500 قتيل في صفوف
المحتاجين بينهم نساء واطفال
ايرانيون يقللون من شان الارقام السابقه
المعلنه ويتحدثون عن حصيله اكبر للضحايا
والمعتقلين والمفقودين جراء استخدام الامن
الايراني
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها ايران هي الاطول
والاكثر دمويه لاستخدام النظام القوه
لفضها ماذا فعل دول الغربيه للتحرك لفرد
عقوبات اضافيه على ايران بسبب عمليات
القتل الجماعي للشعب الايراني كما وصفتها
دول الغربيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الصفحه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]